And we are going to the United States because Donald Trump has warned that if he
arrives at the White House in November he will not protect from 1 Russian attack
NATO allies who do not pay their quotas He has also said that on his first day
of repression he will execute the largest of migrants in U.S.
history.
All this at 1 campaign rally in South Carolina where Trump has congratulated Congress
' refusal to seek 1 new aid to Ukraine and has again his NATO allies for not sufficiently
funding the institution Not only will he not go on defending defaulters against
1 Russian attack but he will encourage the US to do whatever it wants The White
House has called these statements by Trump the dementia
in
1 of
and yes.